A new toxin has been found to kill cancerous
cells while ignoring healthy ones, and it
comes from Brazilian wasps.
And meet the Hedgehog, a robot designed to
explore the surface of a comet.
Vsauce! Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
Researchers at UCLA have helped a paralyzed
man walk by stimulating his nerves and putting
him in a bionic suit. By combining a treatment
called epidural electrical stimulation with
a nerve-stimulating drug, the team was able
to train Mark Pollock's nerves to have a higher
motor threshold so they could connect to the
brain. The treatment is a proof of concept
and the suit acts like training wheels, supporting
the patient's legs and adjusting itself based
on how much assistance is needed. Aside from
walking, the treatment appears to improve
blood pressure, heart rate, and bladder function
to raise the quality of life for quadriplegics.
Eter9.com is a website designed to create
an immortal digital version of yourself.
It learns about your posting habits and use
of language to create what they call your
counterpart, a virtual artificial intelligence
that will post on your behalf even when you’re
not signed on and will continue to keep posting
after you die.
Virtual robots are being used to study how
cooperation amongst certain insects evolved.
The robots were placed in a virtual environment
that simulated a tree with falling leaves,
and then observed over many generations. While
initially the robots behaviors were erratic,
after 2,000 generations of digital breeding
the robots had developed specialized tasks
despite all starting with the same programming.
This discovery not only sheds light on the
evolution of insects, but also suggests that
simulations could be used to improve and adapt
real swarms of unspecialized robots to specific
tasks.
The IceCube Observatory in Antartica has confirmed
the existence of cosmic neutrinos. Neutrinos
are high energy particles that are nearly
impossible to detect due to their ability
to pass through almost anything unaffected.
Detecting cosmic neutrinos is important because
they’re able to carry information across
the universe, like the origins of high energy
cosmic rays, and can even alert us to the
presence of supernovae before they’re visible
from earth.
The climate engineering firm transpolar has
create a membrane that could cool entire cities.
These photonic membranes reflect incoming
sunlight back into space and convert the heat
into infrared light without the use of electricity
or water. They could be used to cool large
areas sustainably, and there’s currently
an installation in Paris showcasing it that
runs until October 4th.
The solar sunflower is a hyper efficient way
of harnessing solar energy.With an energy
efficiency of 80% it uses a liquid cooling
system to draw heat away from the solar collectors
so that it doesn't overheat. A single device
could power 2- 4 houses, but as of now concerns
over its cost and functionality without direct
sunlight could keep it from seeing commercial
use.
Real Virtuality combines motion capture technology
with VR headsets. It allows for multiple users
to interact with a virtual environment and
each other in real time. The rendering of
the environment happens so quickly that two
users can toss a torch to each other without
having to remove their headsets. This represents
a huge step in virtual reality gaming and
could also change the way soldiers, firefighters
and many other professions are trained.
Researchers at the University of San Diego
have created 3D-printed microscopic fish.
Designed for medical purposes these microfish
use iron oxide and platinum nanoparticles
in their head and tail to change direction
and speed. They’re chemically powered,
magnetically steered and could be used to
deliver medicine to different parts of the
body or to sense and remove toxins.
Meanwhile, researchers at Penn State have
created a polymer that self heals when it
comes into contact with water. And it’s
made with genes from a squid. The team found
that squid teeth possess self-healing proteins
which they were able to replicate in the lab.
And they hope to use this to create underwater
fiberoptic cables that can be repaired because
currently if one breaks the cable must be
completely replaced.
Finally, MIT has invented a 3D printer that
can print ten different materials simultaneously.
With Multifab you integrate these two worlds
of traditional manufacturing and 3D printing
and by putting them together you can create
a whole new range of objects that we haven't
been able to make today.
I’m going to leave you printing glass. And
as always - thanks for watching.